bonjour et bienvenue dans ce qui va être
le plus grand match de l'histoire de
céline juste c'est super à charge mais
des espaces entre mes mots c'est
infernal aujourd'hui on joue avec mecha
contre yann et son bilan greg beugnot
faire mal à faire mais on est sur disque
jam c'est un jeu que yann a découvert ça
s'apparente un peu à ces comme le jeu
dans la salle arcades à ba2 le palais at
c'est sûr de l'air le nmq er ok voilà
exactement merci de me faire passer pour
un gros gogol devant la communauté je
t'aime deux comptes de yann et greg
honte au moins 58 heure de jeu chacun
voici une photo du septum de mika voilà
actuellement c'est pour jouer on fait ça
en bo5 cinq matches le premier qu'il ya
trois matches à gagner
c'est parti mais qu'at on est en bas et
les adversaires sont en phase d méga
spectacles etc est cédée fin mais qu'est
ce qui fait que le zerg et tu fais
[ __ ] les mecs mais c'est aux côtés aux
bahamas ambika s'ajoutaient malgré deux
sacrés non tu peux pas serrer la vis aux
maldives ont été placés des moyens je
fais quoi là bas que p&g pas compter sur
toi j'ai pas toujours sans toit du coup
perd ni clinique ste flèches ou bien
caché allez on est bien on désire début
on continue comme ça oui mika et la
passe là bas tu n'as rien tu peux faire
avec mes jambes mécano d'affaires qui
gagnent là c'est gagnant gagnant
la laque est inquiète vas-y oui mais
quand on n'a plus droit à l'erreur on
perd le premier match tu là merci d'en
prouver la voir là j'avais pourtant ce
handicap à l'étape en six étapes et un
triplé
ces parades à match à 0 milles casbah
ave c ils ont beaucoup joué au jeu
contrairement à nous on peut remonter
après j'avoue le mec de droite pour son
style mais a été gagnée quand même des
problèmes et c'est pas possible tu ta
journée mort g voilà voilà ni cacher ça
qu'on veut tayebi qu'un travail
les castors du canda oui mais non j'ai
eu un bug allez mika mais kamikaze
caussens au oui on est bien on est bien
mais quand on est bien on est bien on
renvoie illico presto ya confusion chez
l'ennemi au bazooka en acquérant moi et
l'autre qui va dedans j'y tiens ta ta ta
ta gueule [ __ ] mais si on perd donc si
on perd je te bute a laissé la victoire
mais quelle victoire
oui mika maintenant on a plus de perdre
un match j'ai conscience de ça mais faut
mettre un peu de difficulté ok je savais
que 50 0 est-ce que c'est 50 0 les voilà
carla mar amado mondiale mika 3 suisses
air dans cette vidéo pape et greg passé
là moi à laisser sa peau qu'il faut
qu'je du conflit en face la forme ça
s'embrouille un peu au sein de l'équipe
oui à l'eau commence à remonter c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien on s'attend
c'est mon chemin sans réponse est non
mais bon ça c'est mika ah oui mais quoi
elle a juste eu du lac pardon excusez
moi a fait dire plus car plus le temps
passe tu l'a fait kia il va gagner la
liga a au nom de la gagne et mika
hôpitaux étaient les amis on attire le
problème c'était pas un problème de ce
qu'il s'était un problème de personnages
la fille est pas très fort dans le jeu
gros bullshit mais qui a du coup il a
pris un mode perso il a pris lui bah
voila j'ai même eu le temps de montrer
merci m sachant que celle là on va la
gagner en plus lui qui casse et là il a
tout gagné avant qu'il ait dit zahia
nous passions à côté me casse toi c'est
pas grave ils ont gagné un set
rien est impossible mais ne transpire la
mégère hamelin tu es tout seul mais
n'ont pas mis leur facture à moi tu
l'habitude l'avenir à nos attentes a
gagné 7 au petit trot monté micasa
incroyable ce qui se passe on va gagner
la guerre j'ai tout gagné avec ce qui
nous a mis [ __ ] et font monter me
casser la balle de match 2 ou fla alors
oui oui mika amis car on n'a plus droit
les mêmes écarts attentes en comptant un
sondage sur twitter qu'un abonné a créé
celui qui gagnent la prochaine et la
vraiment de gagner les gars pouvaient
pas refuser une demande abonnés moi
c'est la dernière
ok d'accord il ya une balle de bâtard
non micka mickaël ils ont gagné plus de
francs puisque oui oui oui
non non non non non ah non ok mais
capable quand tu joue vite sinon il met
[Musique]
la vidéo elle va s'appeler quand tu
joues avec ton pote bob quoi toi elles
sont foire iran lé bling mais qu'a
annoncé qu'il va faire mais là vous
l'aurez jamais son nom voilà au nom là
et là on rencontre tout cas l on remonte
les gens crient dans la salle pourquoi
tu me donnes le truc pour naturelles et
responsable américain non mais pourquoi
tu es jouy quitte après un jeu wii allez
les bleus allez c'est bon
home cinéma tchèque a vite fait je peux
pas allée par allée ubisort non on veut
bien donner de l'argent si tu yann si tu
quittes les gens te déclare perdant tu
fait en outre au lof fait-on trop si
j'étais vous et que j'étais abonnée à
shangai âge de se désabonner direct
devant les amis faire c'est de regarder
cette vidéo fallout roos organes attends
je vais l'appeler quand même je vais
l'appeler williams battue c'est ont fait
l'outro tu peux dire au revoir si tu
veux c'est très bien bientôt yann les
amis l'amour est silvio est très simple
si votre ami un set up comme ça refuser
de jouer avec lui vraiment après sa
poule est adaptée vous êtes vous
regardez pas ce qu'il ya de sûr tout le
monde puisse merci greg connard
nous
là